bem-vindo de volta ao Computação Quântica na Prática. Eu sou Olivia Lanes e o episódio de hoje, o três, vai focar em um
experimento de QAOA na escala de utilidade. Se você está conosco desde o início, viu a gente percorrer o
hardware IBM Quantum, o framework dos padrões do Qiskit e as mais recentes e melhores técnicas de mitigação de erros que
pesquisadores e desenvolvedores usam para escalar os circuits quânticos. Sentimos que era realmente importante te dar todo esse
contexto e mostrar a direção para onde estávamos indo, mas agora não há razão para esperar mais para ver todas essas informações em
ação. Agora, algumas coisas para ter em mente antes de começarmos: tudo vai seguir o framework dos padrões do
Qiskit, então vamos percorrer esses passos em ordem. Um: mapear o problema. Dois: otimizar o circuit. Três:
executar com Primitivas. E quatro: pós-processamento ou análise dos resultados. Vamos começar com um exemplo bem pequeno
para que todos possam ter uma boa compreensão desses passos e de seu propósito. Depois vamos discutir um exemplo muito semelhante, mas muito
maior, para mostrar como escalar o problema para o nível de 100 qubits. Vou te dar todas as
ferramentas para que depois desta aula você possa ir em frente e executar esse problema de forma independente. Por último, isso não vai
ser um passo a passo de código. Por mais que tentemos, à medida que progredimos o código fica velho e se torna obsoleto. Então se você acabar
assistindo a esse vídeo um ano depois do lançamento, não quero que você fique preso na sintaxe que pode ter mudado um pouco com o tempo. Em vez disso, esta será uma
discussão detalhada da lógica e do enunciado do problema. No entanto, há um tutorial em notebook que acompanha este
vídeo, que está anexado na descrição abaixo. Acompanhar o código ou consultá-lo depois de
assistir a esta aula e executá-lo você mesmo vai te dar a melhor experiência de aprendizado possível. Então, como um lembrete rápido:
nem todos os problemas computacionais são adequados para a Computação Quântica. Problemas fáceis e cálculos simples não precisam se
beneficiar dessa tecnologia porque os computadores clássicos já são perfeitamente bons em resolvê-los. A partir de 2024, os
três domínios sobre os quais somos mais otimistas são: simular a natureza, processar dados com estrutura complexa
e, por último, a otimização. Problemas de otimização estão entre os mais difíceis problemas computacionais
para resolver eficientemente. Em um problema de otimização, você está procurando o maior ou menor valor possível
para uma determinada função de custo. Porém, para muitos problemas de interesse, encontrar esse extremo se torna exponencialmente mais
difícil com o tamanho do problema. É por isso que fica tão difícil de computar. Por exemplo, você pode imaginar como
pode ser difícil calcular rotas de voo ótimas ou rotas de entrega em todo o país. Nesta aula, vamos
explorar um problema de otimização particular chamado Max cut, que vamos resolver usando um algoritmo quântico
chamado quantum approximation optimization algorithm, ou QAOA. Então o que é o problema Max cut? O
problema de corte máximo é um tipo de problema de otimização combinatorial definido em um grafo, onde o objetivo é
particionar os vértices do grafo em dois subconjuntos, de forma que o número de arestas entre os dois subconjuntos seja
maximizado. Então, por exemplo, neste grafo aqui, cada nó está conectado assim, e o Max cut é mostrado por essa linha sinuosa
que divide os nós no grupo roxo e no grupo cinza. A forma de fazer isso cruzando o maior
número possível de arestas é cortar cinco arestas. Para este grafo aqui, como o grafo é tão pequeno,
não é difícil tentar alguns cortes possíveis no papel ou mesmo de cabeça e perceber que cinco é a melhor opção
possível. Mas imagine se o número de nós dobrasse e depois triplicasse. Rapidamente isso se torna impossível de fazer
manualmente e, após um certo número, fica tão complicado que até supercomputadores têm dificuldade em retornar consistentemente a melhor resposta. Isso porque
o número máximo de cortes escala exponencialmente com o número de nós. Embora isso possa parecer um pouco abstrato,
há muitos problemas do mundo real que podem ser convertidos em um problema Max cut, como detecção de fraudes em finanças, agrupamento de grafos,
design de redes e design de VLSI, além de análise de redes sociais. O
de redes sociais é particularmente fácil de entender. Digamos que você quer encontrar um grupo de indivíduos que têm o maior número de
conexões com outros indivíduos em uma plataforma de rede social, a fim de identificar usuários poderosos ou pessoas que têm
mais influência em um grupo. As empresas realmente tentam fazer isso com bastante frequência. Por último, o Max cut é frequentemente
uma sub-rotina de um problema maior, então pode não estar definindo a aplicação real, mas ser usado nos bastidores. É
muito mais comum do que você pode pensar ingenuamente. Agora é hora de começar. O
primeiro passo é criar nosso grafo. Você pode fazer isso importando um pacote Python chamado rustworkx. Defina quantos
nós você está trabalhando especificando o número n, depois adicione seus nós ao grafo G. Você também vai ter
que desenhar suas arestas. Vamos fazer isso manualmente listando-as em um array como este, onde você mostra o último
número que especifica o peso da aresta, ou quão fortemente os dois nós especificados estão conectados. Aqui vamos
usar um peso de um para todos, mas você pode se divertir brincando com o peso depois e vendo como a solução
muda. Para ter uma noção do que peso significa neste contexto, voltemos ao nosso exemplo de rede social. Você pode
pensar nesse peso como o quanto uma pessoa pode ser influente para outra. Sua conexão com seu cônjuge ou parente
provavelmente receberia um peso maior do que alguém que é apenas um conhecido. Agora desenha o teu grafo.
O tutorial anexo vai te mostrar a sintaxe correta. Primeiro, antes de considerar como
mapear esse problema em um circuit quântico, vamos construir algum contexto sobre como o problema Max cut se torna um problema de otimização
em primeiro lugar. Começamos considerando primeiro a minimização de uma função f de x, onde a entrada x é um
vetor n-dimensional cujos componentes correspondem a cada nó do grafo. Vamos nos referir a essa função daqui em diante
como nossa função de custo. Depois precisamos restringir cada um desses componentes a ser zero ou
um, significando aqui de um lado ou do outro do corte. Podemos escrever uma função como
um par de nós x_i e x_j que nos diz se a aresta correspondente está no corte. Assim, a quantidade x_i + x_j
menos x_i x_j identifica se a aresta está no corte. Se essa quantidade é igual
a um, isso implica que a aresta está no corte; caso contrário é zero e a aresta não está. O problema de encontrar o
número máximo de arestas no corte pode então ser formulado como a maximização dessa função. Em seguida, vamos
adicionar um sinal de menos global a essa função, tornando o novo problema equivalente a encontrar o mínimo dessa função
em vez disso, e portanto o mínimo de f de x neste caso será quando o número de arestas percorridas pelo corte for
máximo. Escolhemos enquadrar esse problema como um problema de minimização porque isso nos permite depois mapeá-lo em um problema de
minimização de energia, também conhecido como encontrar o estado fundamental, que é no que os computadores quânticos são naturalmente muito bons.
Mas lembra que ainda não há nada relacionado à Computação Quântica aqui. Ainda precisamos reformular esse problema em
algo que um computador quântico possa entender. Agora estamos prontos para arregaçar as mangas e começar o trabalho. O
primeiro passo é mapear o problema em um circuit quântico. Pode não ser óbvio como vamos
ir de um grafo como o que acabamos de desenhar para um circuit quântico, mas vamos devagar. Lembra que estamos
tentando resolver esse problema Max cut usando QAOA. No algoritmo QAOA, queremos ter um operador,
o hamiltoniano, que será usado para representar a função de custo do nosso problema, bem como um
circuit parametrizado, o ansatz ou estado de teste, que usaremos para representar estados quânticos que são palpites educados ou candidatos
para a solução do problema. Podemos amostrar desses estados candidatos e então avaliá-los
usando a função de custo. Neste caso, a função de custo é f de x, mas precisamos expressá-la de uma
forma que pareça nativa ao computador quântico. Para isso, vamos aproveitar uma série de transformações matemáticas
para expressar f de x como uma função de energia, o hamiltoniano. O primeiro passo do
processo é expressar o problema de minimização de f de x como um problema de otimização binária irrestrita quadrática,
ou QUBO. O QUBO é uma forma geral de formular esses problemas de otimização combinatorial.
Aqui Q é uma matriz N por N de números reais. N corresponde ao número de
nós em nosso grafo, cinco neste exemplo, e X é o mesmo vetor de variáveis binárias da formulação
inicial. Para executar efetivamente o algoritmo QAOA, precisamos expressar nosso problema de otimização em termos de um
hamiltoniano, que é um operador matemático que representa a energia total de um sistema. Especificamente, queremos
criar um hamiltoniano de função de custo que tenha a propriedade de que seu estado fundamental, ou valor próprio mínimo,
corresponda ao mínimo da função que codifica o número máximo de cortes no grafo g. Uma vez que
tivermos esse hamiltoniano, tudo que precisamos fazer para resolver nosso problema de otimização é preparar o estado fundamental do hamiltoniano no computador quântico. Depois,
amostrar desse estado, com alta probabilidade, vai resultar na solução da minimização de f de X. Acontece que
temos sorte, porque o problema QUBO é muito intimamente relacionado a, e na verdade computacionalmente equivalente a,
um dos hamiltonianos mais famosos e onipresentes da física: o hamiltoniano de Ising. Para escrever o problema QUBO
como este hamiltoniano de Ising, tudo que precisamos fazer é uma simples troca de variáveis para passar de
variáveis booleanas 0 e 1 para variáveis de spin menos um e um. Esse passo é
simples; está mostrado com mais detalhes no apêndice do notebook anexo para os interessados, mas ao final a minimização desta expressão QUBO
é a mesma que a minimização desta expressão. Reescrevendo novamente de forma ligeiramente diferente e
temos nosso hamiltoniano de função de custo, onde o mínimo da expressão representa o estado fundamental e Z
se torna o operador de Pauli Z, enquanto B é um coeficiente escalar real. Agora que temos nosso
hamiltoniano, é direto reescrevê-lo em termos de dois operadores Pauli ZZ locais que se converterão facilmente em
dois gates quânticos ZZ em nosso circuit quântico. Consulta o notebook associado para ver como isso é feito, mas o resultado
é dado por essa linha aqui. Nota que em nosso exemplo existem
seis objetos ou strings de Pauli porque cada um representa uma aresta no grafo. O comprimento da string corresponde ao número
de nós, então IIIzz são cinco nós, e a string será composta de
identidades em todas as posições, exceto nos índices dos nós envolvidos em uma aresta, que terão termos Z. No Qiskit,
as strings de bits representando qubits são indexadas ao contrário. Por exemplo, uma aresta entre os nós 0 e 1 será codificada como
IIIZZ. Com o hamiltoniano escrito em termos de Paulis, estamos prontos para construir nosso
circuit quântico. Este circuit quântico vai nos ajudar a amostrar boas soluções do computador quântico. O algoritmo QAOA
é inspirado no teorema adiabático, que afirma que se começamos no estado fundamental do hamiltoniano dependente do tempo
e se o hamiltoniano evoluir lentamente o suficiente, dado tempo suficiente, o estado final será o estado fundamental
do hamiltoniano final. O QAOA pode ser pensado como a versão Trotter discreta do algoritmo quântico
adiabático, onde cada passo de Trotter representa uma camada que chamaremos de P. Então,
em vez de evoluir de um estado para o outro, em cada camada de P vamos alternar entre nosso hamiltoniano de
função de custo e algo chamado hamiltoniano mixer, sobre o qual ouviremos mais em breve. Mas o ponto que quero fazer
é que o QAOA tem a vantagem de ser mais rápido do que o algoritmo quântico adiabático, mas retorna soluções
aproximadas em vez da ótima. No limite onde o número de camadas vai para o infinito, o QAOA converge para o caso adiabático,
mas claro, isso é muito caro computacionalmente. Para criar nosso circuit quântico,
vamos aplicar operadores alternados aqui parametrizados por gamma e beta, que
representarão a discretização da evolução temporal. Então, novamente, as três partes principais
do circuit QAOA são: um, o estado de teste inicial em cinza, que é o estado fundamental
do mixer a partir do estado adiabático, criado pela aplicação de um Hadamard gate aplicado a cada qubit. Dois:
a evolução da função de custo, que já temos em roxo escuro. E três: a evolução sob o hamiltoniano
mixer, que ainda não discutimos, em roxo claro. Agora, nosso hamiltoniano inicial é
chamado de mixer porque seu estado fundamental é a superposição de todas as strings de bits de interesse possíveis, forçando
assim uma mistura de todas as soluções possíveis no início. O hamiltoniano mixer é a simples soma das operações Pauli X
em cada nó do grafo. O Qiskit permite usar um operador mixer personalizado diferente se desejar, mas
neste caso vamos usar o padrão. Então, novamente, você pode ver que com o Qiskit muito do trabalho é
removido para a gente, tornando trivial chegar ao hamiltoniano mixer e ao estado inicial. O único trabalho que tivemos de fazer foi
encontrar a função de custo. Cada iteração desses operadores é chamada de camada. Essas camadas podem ser vistas como
discretizações da evolução temporal do sistema conforme descrito anteriormente. O padrão alternado vem da
decomposição de Trotter e aproxima as funções exponenciais de matrizes que não comutam. Em geral, quanto mais camadas ou
passos incluirmos, mais perto estaremos da evolução em tempo contínuo e, em teoria, mais preciso será o resultado.
Mas para este exemplo vamos começar amostrando com apenas duas camadas. Lembra que tanto o hamiltoniano de função de custo quanto
o mixer são parametrizados. Ainda precisamos chegar aos valores ótimos de gamma e
beta. Reconheço que foi muita informação e, se você está vendo esse tipo de matemática pela primeira vez, pode ser complicado. Por sorte, uma das coisas incríveis
do Qiskit é que muito do que acabamos de ver pode ser feito automaticamente sem um grande esforço do usuário. É bom entender o que está
acontecendo nos bastidores, especialmente quando escalamos para experimentos maiores, mas você não vai ter que fazer todo esse trabalho
manualmente toda vez. Agora mapeamos nosso problema em um circuit quântico. Foi um pouco de trabalho,
mas não te preocupa: fica mais fácil e mais intuitivo quanto mais você faz. Agora estamos prontos para passar ao passo dois:
otimizar nosso circuit para o hardware. Enquanto o circuit que acabamos de criar parece bem simples e é
útil para construir uma compreensão intuitiva, lembra que o chip quântico não entende o que é esse bloco abstrato.
Precisamos transformá-lo em uma série de gates de um e dois qubits que são nativos do hardware. E quando digo
nativo, quero dizer que será refatorado para o que pode ser executado diretamente nos qubits. Tais circuits são
chamados de escritos na arquitetura do conjunto de instruções do backend, que pode ser abreviada como circuits ISA.
O módulo transpiler do SDK do Qiskit oferece uma série de passes de transpilação que podem
realizar uma ampla gama de transformações de circuit. Queremos garantir que nosso circuit está otimizado para nosso
propósito. Lembra da nossa aula anterior que o processo de transpilação envolve vários passos: mapeamento dos
qubits no circuit, ou as variáveis de decisão, para qubits físicos no dispositivo; desdobramento das instruções no
circuit quântico para as instruções nativas do hardware que o backend realmente entende; roteamento de quaisquer
qubits no circuit que interagem diretamente para qubits físicos que são adjacentes entre si.
E, como sempre, mais detalhes sobre isso podem ser encontrados no site de documentação.
Agora vem um passo empolgante onde vamos escolher em qual backend executar nosso circuit. Na verdade, temos que fazer isso
antes do passo de transpilação porque o transpiler otimiza de forma diferente para processadores diferentes. Esse é mais um motivo pelo qual é
importante que o Qiskit possa automatizar tanto dessa etapa. Você não gostaria de ter que otimizar seu circuit manualmente,
o que pode ser feito mas às vezes é complicado e muito demorado, só para perceber que na verdade quer executar
seu circuit em um processador diferente com propriedades diferentes e ter que fazer todo esse trabalho novamente. Passe
seu backend de escolha pela função do transpiler e não se esqueça de especificar seu nível de otimização. Desta
vez selecionei o nível de otimização três, que é o mais alto e exaustivo nível de otimização.
E é isso para o passo dois. Meu circuit foi transpilado automaticamente e eu o desenhei aqui para que
você possa ver como foi traduzido em gates de um e dois qubits. Agora é hora do passo três:
executar o circuit com as Primitivas do Qiskit. Até agora transpilamos o circuit deixando os parâmetros gamma e
beta intocados, mas não podemos realmente executar o circuit sem especificar o valor desses parâmetros. No fluxo de trabalho
do QAOA, os parâmetros ótimos do QAOA são encontrados em um loop de otimização iterativo onde executamos uma série de
avaliações do circuit e usamos um otimizador clássico para encontrar os parâmetros ótimos de beta e gamma. Porém, precisamos
começar de algum lugar. Então implementei alguns palpites iniciais para gamma_1, gamma_2 e beta_1, beta_2 de Pi/2 e Pi
respectivamente. Também quero que tu notes que usaremos um otimizador para encontrar soluções melhores para gamma e beta,
e como estou calculando apenas duas camadas por agora, isso é tudo que preciso. Mas se você fizer um circuit QAOA mais preciso,
incluiria mais camadas e portanto precisaria de um gamma e beta otimizados para cada camada
sequencial. Agora vamos dar uma pausa aqui para lembrar nossas opções de Primitivas. Temos o estimator e
o sampler. Qual você acha que vamos usar para este tipo de trabalho? Bem, não importa qual você tenha
escolhido, você está correto. Vamos usar tanto o estimator quanto o sampler. Para o loop de otimização
inicial precisaremos do estimator, mas usaremos o sampler depois para ler a
solução final. Agora estamos quase prontos para executar nosso algoritmo, prometo. Mas muito rapidamente, é importante notar que você pode
enviar seu trabalho de várias formas diferentes, chamadas de modos de execução. Primeiro temos o modo job: um único
pedido primitivo do estimator ou sampler feito sem um gerenciador de contexto. Os circuits e entradas são empacotados como blocos
unificados primitivos, ou PUBs, e enviados como uma tarefa de execução no computador
quântico. O modo batch é um gerenciador multi-job para executar eficientemente um experimento que consiste em um conjunto
de trabalhos independentes. Use o modo batch para enviar múltiplos trabalhos primitivos simultaneamente. Modo session: uma janela dedicada
para executar um workload multi-job. Isso permite que usuários premium experimentem algoritmos variacionais de uma forma mais
previsível e até executem múltiplos experimentos simultaneamente, aproveitando o paralelismo da
stack. Use sessions para fluxos de trabalho iterativos e experimentos que requerem acesso dedicado. Para um experimento QAOA,
uma session seria uma boa escolha se você tiver acesso a ela, já que precisará tentar múltiplos circuits para diferentes valores de beta
e gamma. Ok, agora vamos voltar ao nosso problema de otimização. Já
definimos o hamiltoniano de função de custo HC, e o fluxo de trabalho completo é este: o algoritmo QAOA
começa inicializando os qubits no estado de superposição e depois aplica o ansatz com P camadas. Ele
inicializa os parâmetros gamma e beta e depois executa o circuit usando a primitiva estimator. Uma vez que calculamos
os valores de expectativa, usaremos um otimizador SciPy chamado COBYLA. O COBYLA
otimiza a função de custo classicamente fora do QPU. Uma vez que esses valores de gamma e beta foram atualizados, nós
repetimos. Faremos isso até que o valor da função de custo geral tenha convergido e alcançado o menor valor.
Então selecionaremos os valores de gamma e beta que correspondem a esse valor de baixo custo e executaremos o circuit uma última
vez, agora usando o sampler. Este é o resultado de eu executar o otimizador COBYLA com meus palpites iniciais. Aqui você pode ver
que o valor da função de custo ao longo das iterações começa um pouco errático, sobe e desce, mas
depois se estabiliza em um valor baixo. Usaremos esses últimos valores de gamma e beta que correspondem à avaliação de
função de custo mínimo para executar o circuit uma última vez e amostrar a string de bits que nos dará o Max
cut. Agora, usando nossos valores otimizados para os gammas e betas, vamos executar o circuit uma última vez para encontrar a melhor
string de bits possível usando o sampler. Listei os valores específicos que estou usando aqui, mas lembra que quando você tentar
fazer isso ou até mesmo reexecutar o mesmo notebook tutorial, esses valores podem mudar ligeiramente. Agora vamos executar
nosso circuit otimizado com esses valores e encontrar nossa solução candidata para o nosso problema Max cut. Se você estava usando
sessions, isso não é mais necessário já que estamos executando apenas um último trabalho. Agora finalmente vamos ver a
etapa de pós-processamento e encontrar nossa solução final. Primeiro vamos plotar todas as
combinações possíveis de nós que convertemos em strings de bits como um histograma. Você pode ver imediatamente que
quando executei encontrei quatro soluções e destacadas em roxo as que são mais prováveis do que qualquer outra solução.
A string de bits solução mais alta e portanto mais provável é 01010. Nota que a ordem dos qubits
está invertida no gráfico. Olhando para a solução mais provável, notamos que os nós 0 e 3 estão agrupados juntos
e similarmente para os nós 1, 2 e 4. Podemos finalmente plotar a string de bits mais provável
de volta como um grafo e lembra que a string de bits simplesmente corresponde aos números dos nós e se estão incluídos,
marcados com um, ou não incluídos, marcados com zero, em nosso agrupamento. Quando desenhamos o corte agora, podemos ver com nossos olhos a
linha aproximada para o melhor corte, que representa o agrupamento ideal de todos os cinco nós, que desenhei aqui.
Uma coisa que quero discutir aqui, no entanto, é que a solução correta não é única
por causa da simetria deste grafo. Existem múltiplas soluções corretas. Em vez de ter os nós 0 e 3 dentro
do corte, poderíamos ter os nós 2 e 4 incluídos, e você pode ver que tudo que precisei fazer foi girar meu corte para
incluir esses novos pontos. Essa solução de cinco permanece a mesma.
Vamos dar outra olhada no histograma e nas quatro soluções mais prováveis por um momento. As duas últimas soluções são as
que acabamos de plotar e estão igualmente corretas. Mas não é só isso: também poderíamos inverter as cores de todas
as soluções corretas, e desta vez pensamos nos nós como estando dentro versus fora do corte. No
slide anterior identificamos duas soluções corretas únicas, mas na verdade existem duas soluções a mais: uma correspondendo ao
oposto de cada uma delas. Veja como aqui, onde desenhei as duas soluções restantes, tudo que fiz foi inverter as
cores. Agora o único problema é que o algoritmo não encontrou ou identificou essa quarta última solução como
uma das quatro respostas mais prováveis. Ela ficou em quinto lugar. A quarta solução que o algoritmo identificou
é na verdade incorreta, e se você a desenhasse veria que essa solução tem apenas quatro cortes. Como as outras
têm cinco, e quatro é claramente menor que cinco, isso está obviamente errado. O ponto aqui
é que este é um algoritmo aproximado. Ele não é infalível e não está correto 100% do tempo. Você tem que
usar seu próprio conhecimento e compreensão para fazer uma verificação de sanidade das soluções. Vale destacar que
esse erro pode surgir de vários lugares. Pode ser a natureza aproximada do próprio algoritmo e o pequeno
número de camadas que escolhi usar. Pode ser um erro de amostragem finita, que poderia ser reduzido se eu aumentasse o
número de shots no meu experimento. Ou pode ser um erro de leitura, já que a quarta solução real está errada por apenas um
bit. A razão pela qual estou apontando todas essas possibilidades é porque é isso que é necessário para se tornar completamente um
praticante de Computação Quântica. Você precisa entender o desempenho do hardware e como isso pode contribuir
para certos tipos de erros e como corrigi-los. No entanto, não vamos esquecer que havia
32 possíveis soluções de string de bits e que as quatro soluções reais estavam incluídas nos cinco primeiros
melhores candidatos, e usei apenas duas camadas para encontrar isso. Em geral, se eu quero aumentar minhas chances de encontrar o
melhor Max cut todas as vezes, eu aumentaria a profundidade das camadas. Existem algumas sutilezas nisso, mas isso é para um episódio
posterior. Agora vou deixar você tentar por conta própria, mas desta vez você vai usar 100
qubits. Então se começarmos desenhando nosso grafo de 100 qubits, você pode ver que não é mais simples ou sequer possível
identificar visualmente onde o Max cut ocorreria. Existem simplesmente possibilidades demais para poder escolhê-lo manualmente, mas
resolver esse problema usando QAOA ainda é totalmente viável, e você pode seguir exatamente o mesmo fluxo de trabalho que usamos para 5
qubits. Estou prestes a te mandar sozinho e te desafiar a tentar fazer esse experimento, mas antes vamos
resumir. Lembra que os seis passos de qualquer trabalho QAOA são os seguintes: um, definir
um hamiltoniano de custo tal que seu estado fundamental codifique a solução para o problema de otimização. Dois, definir um
hamiltoniano mixer. Três, construir os operadores correspondentes aos
hamiltonianos exponencializados. Quatro, construir o circuit, que consistirá no estado fundamental inicial do mixer e em
camadas repetidas alternadas da função de custo e da evolução sob os hamiltonianos mixer. Cinco, preparar um estado inicial e
usar técnicas de computação clássica para otimizar os parâmetros. Seis, executar o circuit, medir as strings de bits de saída
em busca da solução mais provável. Agora algumas coisas a notar aqui: usei
o nível de otimização três para o meu exemplo de 5 qubits, mas talvez não fosse necessário e a resposta correta poderia
ser retornada na maioria das vezes em um nível de otimização mais baixo, porque a profundidade do circuit era bastante baixa para o caso de 5
qubits. Mas para os 100 qubits e uma grande profundidade de circuit, você quase certamente precisará do mais alto nível de
otimização para encontrar a resposta certa. Também tenha em mente que uma das partes mais desafiadoras de um fluxo de trabalho típico de escala de utilidade
é a etapa de mapeamento e encontrar um grafo que corresponda bem à topologia heavy hex da IBM. Se você estivesse
fazendo esse trabalho do zero, seria indubitavelmente onde você dedicaria a maior parte do seu tempo. Por agora, essa parte foi
feita para você porque esse não é o ponto principal deste exercício. Mas tenha em mente que é algo que vamos
exigir praticar. Executar um trabalho em grande escala nem sempre é simples. Vamos nos aprofundar nisso
ainda mais no episódio 4. Seu circuit final vai obviamente parecer muito mais bagunçado do que o circuit executado em 5 qubits.
Mas por outro lado, acho que olhar para esse circuit e ver quantos gates ele tem, sabendo que você
tem a capacidade de realmente executar isso em processadores quânticos reais, é bastante
impressionante. E esta foi minha solução final. Você pode ver que o algoritmo é certamente capaz de agrupar esses
nós em dois grupos, alegadamente identificando o melhor Max cut que os divide. Ir dos dois conjuntos
para a linha Max cut em si é trivial: onde quer que a cor mude ao longo das linhas que conectam os nós, indica
onde a linha Max cut deve ser desenhada. Quando executei, o valor Max cut que consegui alcançar foi
84. Então tenta você mesmo e me conta nos comentários se consegues algo similar. Tenta três camadas, talvez quatro. Tenta
mudar os pesos entre os nós e veja como isso muda o resultado. Existem muitos experimentos interessantes
que podemos executar com QAOA. Agora lembra que não é garantido que acabei de encontrar a melhor solução
possível. Sabemos que é uma boa solução, mas por diversão te desafio a tentar me superar. Vê se consegues algo
melhor do que 84. Em conclusão, o QAOA é um algoritmo muito dinâmico
e há muitas heurísticas e muito ainda a ser explorado. Ele oferece muito espaço para aprender coisas novas
sobre o campo da otimização em geral. Houve muito trabalho recente no espaço de otimização,
evidenciado por todos os artigos de arquivo que foram publicados recentemente online sobre QAOA ou otimização. E o que é
muito legal é que finalmente nem todos esses artigos são artigos teóricos. Os teóricos têm trabalhado e estudando
QAOA por anos, mas agora os experimentalistas estão se envolvendo porque finalmente temos o hardware,
como os processadores da IBM, que são capazes de executar muitos desses experimentos. Estamos passando do espaço imaginativo
para o mundo real, e isso é muito empolgante. Sim, ainda há muito trabalho a ser feito e ainda
há muitos erros que precisamos descobrir como lidar, mas estamos progredindo rapidamente. E você que está assistindo a este
vídeo, se chegou até aqui, é capaz de executar esses experimentos por conta própria. Por favor, vá tentar executar seu próprio
experimento de 100 qubits e nos conta como foi. Segue o tutorial e você estará em boas mãos. E se você
tiver alguma dúvida ou ficar preso, não se preocupa. Todos nós nos sentimos assim ou tivemos essas mesmas dúvidas quando começamos
a aprender. Dê o seu melhor, nos conta com quais dúvidas você se deparar e até a próxima.
[Música]